[Musique]
nous sommes au royaume du Mont-Blanc à
chamoni capitale mondiale du ski et de
l'alpinisme au pied des 4810 m du toit
de l'Europe aucune vallée habitée dans
le monde ne bénéficie d'un tel
environnement 10000 habitants 60000 lits
l'école nationale du ski et de
l'alpinisme est le premier centre de
secours européen chamoni est une ville
avant d'être une station en haute saison
la population atteint jusqu'à 100000
personnes attiré par la majesté d'un
site
unique
[Applaudissements]
blotti à 1000 m d'altitude au pied du
massif le plus célèbre des Alpes sur 20
km à la confluence des frontières
suisses françaises et italiennes la
vallée de chamoni jouit d'une réputation
internationale chamoni offre une gamme
complète d'hôtels d'appartements en
résidence locativ et de Git d'étape ici
le ski n'a pas d'équivalent les
descentes sont longues le paysage
[Musique]
omniprésent
toutes les activités hivernales y sont
possibles et cela dès le plus jeune âge
en luge ou à ski sur les pistes du
Savoie où nous retrouvons Lorine guide
du
patrimoine bonjour bienvenue dans la
vallée de chamony si cette vallée
magnifique et célèbre pour ces glaciers
ces montagnes et ces haut sommet elle
n'en demeure pas moins un terrain jeu
ludique même pour les enfants pour toute
la famille nous sommes ici face au
Mont-Blanc sur le Clos du savoir en fond
de vallée c'est une des pistes
débutantes où les enfants avec les
moniteurs de ski prennent leurs
premières
leçons quand on pense à la vallée de
chamony on pense surtout à chamoni la
ville avec ses 10000 habitants mais il
ne faut pas oublier aussi qu'il y a de
nombreux hameau de nombreux villages
avec chacun leur authenticité et leur
spécificités comme le village du tour le
village d'Argentière ce sont tous ces
villages qui F la diversité de la vallée
de chamoni et chaque village est
surplombé par un glacier qui porte son
nom comme le glacier du Tour
d'Argentière le glacer de tacona le
glacer des
Bossons je vous invite à une visite de
la ville et à la découverte de son
histoire nous nous trouvons au cœur de
de la ville de chamoni Montblanc et
derrière moi se trouve la statue de
Jacques Balma et de horas benénedict de
Saur qui sont les deux membres
fondateurs on va dire du mythe
chamoniard avec la première conquête la
première ascension du Mont-Blanc en
1786 les premiers touristes sont arrivés
à chamoni en 1741 avec deux Anglais et
quand on regarde chamoni autour de nous
on se rend compte que finalement c'est
le tourisme qui a apporté cette
architecture éoclyite c'est le mélange
des genrees chamonie
en 1901 l'arrivée du train dans la
vallée met un terme à l'activité des
diligences le développement touristique
d'école la vallée accueille les premiers
Jeux Olympiques d'hiver en 1924 les
compétitions se succèdent au cours du
20e siècle et grâce à Lucien Smith
scouté James scouté Charles bon champion
du monde de slalom en 1962 chamoni est
consacré station
hivernale les hôtels se structurent et
associés à l'habitat traditionnel ils
offrent à chamoni son cachet
original aujourd'hui cette vallée est
devenue la capitale du ski et de
l'alpinisme hivernal on pratique ici une
glisse en toute liberté et karine Ruby
championne olympique de snowboard montre
que les sportifs Chamoniards savent
trouver leur
[Musique]
chemin
et maintenant je vous invite à rejoindre
François au sommet du brevvent pour vous
aussi découvrir la vallée sous son
aspect le plus enneigé et profiter aussi
des plaisirs associés à la
glisse à son époque la construction du
téléphérique qui donne accès au domaine
du Brévent fut un véritable défi à la
nature aujourd'hui modernisé il permet
d'atteindre l'altitude de
[Musique]
m chamonie la magie de chamonie pour le
ski c'est c'est cette possibilité de se
retrouver propulsé en altitude
immédiatement à porter de Ben ou passer
de d'un fond de vallée au à la haute
montagne c'est
[Musique]
extraordinaireque ça c'est bon
ici ce qui est magnifique c'est la
situation balconique face au au
Mont-Blanc et à du midi il y a ces
différentes
aiguilles on va pouvoir descendre en ski
passant par derrière on va se retrouver
jusqu'à plan Pras à 2000
m aujourd'hui c'est une neige excellente
c'est une neige dure et froide mais pas
gelée c'est un temps uneige déjà resté
sur la
[Musique]
piste François comme d'autres skieur a
entamé la fameuse piste noire Charles
bon parfaitement damée qui se développe
sur plus de 600 m de dénivélation le
SOMUM du
[Musique]
brvant
le ski dans la vallée de chamoni exige
une sécurité renforcée et une vigilance
de tous les instants pour les pisteurs
et les autorités communales ces
questions de sécurité sont la
préoccupation principale de Jean-Louis
Verdier guide moniteur et adjoint à la
sécurité montagne de la mairie de
chamoni chamoni est un site difficile
très compliqué à comprendre les chutes
de neige sont souvent énormes donc il
faut prendre des précautions s'informer
avant de partir n'importe où là vous
avez un exemple concret derrière moi
puisque vous avez un panneau qui indique
qu'à partir de cette corde on va sur sur
un domaine hors piste donc on prévient
les personnes qui souhaitent aller dans
ce domaine là qui a des risques ce
panneau est mis en trois langue pour
permettre à tous les étrangers de bien
comprendre qu'il y a danger après la
cororde la diversité on la trouve déjà à
partir du brésvent la piste sur laquelle
nous sommes aujourd'hui où on peut faire
un ski facile un ski de débutant et puis
on trouve des pentes très très raid à
partir de laquelle on peut faire du ski
freeide du ski hors
[Musique]
piste quand on remonte dans la vallée il
la Flégère la Flégère qui qui est qui
est un domaine extraordinaire puisqu'on
a une vue exceptionnelle sur le massif
du Mont-Blanc et là on a un ski du du
ski moyen à ce
facile
quand on va sur le haut de la vallée on
trouve les grands montais et là les
grands montais c'est un domaine fabuleux
ça s'adresse quand même à des skieurs
chevronnais voir très très bon
skieurs dans la vallée plusieurs
couloirs d'avalanche sont recensés et la
majesté des lieux n' dégale que les
dangers qui peuvent en découler pour que
sur les pistes le ski reste un plaisir
un énorme travail de sécurisation est
réalisé et le horpiste qui fait la
renommée de chamoni reste sous la
responsabilité de
[Musique]
chacun ici la particularité du ski
réside dans les différents domaines
skiables relié par des bus ou le train
un vaste espace sur lequel on peut
évoluer au moyen d'un forfait unique le
domaine du brevvant est relié à celui de
la Flégère il conjugue altitude qualité
de neige et ensoleillement les les
pistes du village du Tour permettent de
rejoindre le hameau de valorine ces
domaines sont accessibles à
tous mais sur certains domaine gare aux
couloirs abruptes et aux crevasses à
chamoni 150 guides et 250 moniteurs de
ski sont disponibles pour vous encadrer
en observant toutes les règles de
sécurité la dimension alpine de ces
espaces haut montagne fait que bon
nombre des moniteurs de ski de chamoni
ont également la qualification de guide
de haute
montagne
[Musique]
nous retrouvons maintenant François qui
achève sa descente de la piste Charles
bon au
brévant pour lui maintenant direction
léser toi ici y tu es prêt ça va faire
je vous présente Patrick péren animateur
du CEP Mont-Blanc avec qui je vais
descendre tout tout à l'heure en
parapente là je viens de faire une
descente extraordinaire je vais
enchaîner avec un vol en biplace c'est
ce qui s'appelle être au bon moment au
bon
endroit il y a deux choses importantes
c'est que un ce soit solide une comme ça
ça tient 230 kg parce que ça c'est aussi
pour le moral du passager qu'on le dit
et puis la deuxième raison c'est que les
suspentes elles tiennent la voile sur sa
forme donc on démêle très
précautionneusement en manière de pas
avoir de
nœud
et
voilà on met un casque pour deux raisons
c'est que un c'est obligatoirere sa voie
puisqu un arrêtépectoral et de c'est
l'inverse de la ceinture de sécurité il
vaut mieux un grand bruit qu'un petit
choc le vol avant tout c'est de la
glisse et dans la vallée de chamoni
c'est l'égal du paysage que vous avez pu
voir toute la journée qu'on fréquente un
peu avec plus
d'altitude on pratique ça sur d'autres
sites que plan pr du style Aiguille du
Midi le Mont Blanc pour les sportifs ou
le tacu et puis des vols aussi
touristiques du style la vallée blanche
ou le vol des grand mon qui sont des
vols fabuleux dans la vallée qu'on peut
pratiquer l'hiver et
l'été dans
l'X là alors à 3 tu y vas 1 2
3 le le moment du décollage c'est
vraiment un oiseau on saute pas dans la
pente on va glisser c'est la voile qui
vole le moment du décollage je crois que
c'est vraiment le moment le plus
fabuleux on est arraché du sol on va pas
sauter dans un trou après le vol c'est
un court instant de vie mais c'est une
vie en concentrée c'est la même
[Musique]
chose à la pointe des sports de montagne
chamoni est également un des royaumes du
parapante si à l'origine bon nombre
d'alpinistes ont utilisé ce moyen afin
de regagner la vallée au plus vite
cette activité est aujourd'hui une
discipline sportive à part
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entière extra merci le C merci Patrick
plaisir toi et Manu top merci c'était
magique c'était génial l'enchaînement
ski parapante c'est absolument
fabuleux qu'est-ce que tu fais là
Mar B bien et toi tu par en balade ouais
1000 m plus bas sur l'air d'atterrissage
Patrick Petrini retrouve son ami Marc
ladaré il y a encore beaucoup de
crevasses c'est pas tellement tellement
bouché tout mat Saco et muni de ses skis
Marc veut profiter de cette journée
splendide pour entreprendre la mythique
descente de la Vallée Blanche parcouru
chaque année par 80000 skieurs du monde
entier accessible depuis le centre de
chamoni le téléphérique de l'Aiguille du
Midi propulse les skieurs et les
touristes à 3842 m d'altitude à la gare
de départ Marc et ses amis ont
rendez-vous avec leur guide Olivier
Greber alors dis-moi un petit peu
comment sont les conditions commencer
par emprunter donc le téléphérique de
l'Aiguille du Midi sur deux tronçons on
part de la gare ici arriver jusqu'au
Plan de l'Aiguille Plan de l'Aiguille on
va monter jusqu'au sommet et au sommet
on ira faire un tour sur la terrasse
panoramique c'est plutôt sympa on a en
plus une journée fabuleuse aujourd'hui
allez en
route et
h né de l'imagination d'un ingénieur
italien c'est en 1955 que la
construction du téléphérique de
l'Aiguille du Midi est achevée le
chantier de la plus haute et de la plus
célèbre remontée mécanique du monde fut
une véritable épopée l'ascension du
câble du deuxè tronçon en 1950 fut
mémorable C guides y seront 3 km de
filin en 2 jours par la face nord sur
1500 m de dénivelé d'un seul tenant et
sans aucun pilone le deuxième tronçon
permet de relier le Plan de l'Aiguille
au sommet truffé de galerie
[Applaudissements]
monter le câble au sommet de l'Aiguille
a été un bel exploit technique creuser
les tunnels les ponts maintenant ça
paraît d'une
facilité déconcertante à cette époque là
ça a été un bel exploit technique là on
va se diriger vers l'ascenseur qui passe
au milieu du python central pour aller
sur la terrasse
sommital on va il y a des tunnels on va
passer venez voir
hein c'est la bonne magnif ah mon il y a
3 jours
voilà par
là alors nous voilz ici au sommet de
l'Aiguille he
3842 m le Montblanc se trouve au-dessus
de nous encore 1000 m au-udessus de nous
puisquil est à 4800 10
[Musique]
m au terme d'un voyage vertigineux c'est
l'univers de la haute montagne avec un
panorama à
360° 2800 m plus bas la vallée de
chamoni et au cœur du toit de l'Europe
le paysage grandiose des sommets de 4000
m des Alpes suisses et
italiennes mais attention à cette
altitude la raréfaction de l'oxygène
diminue les capacités physiques
d'environ 20
%. l'arête vous allez voir est
relativement fine mais elle passe très
bien hein on a des grosses cordes pour
se tenir sur les côtés et encordé vous
allez voir que ça pose aucun problème on
va descendre tranquillement
[Musique]
gentiment on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde sur l'arête beaucoup
de monde également sans guide on peut
considérer que c'est pas raisonnable du
tout de se promener sur un glacier sans
avoir de guide dans la Vallée Blanche un
guide va être la sécuré pour vous
déplacer en avant
allons-y donc là on a vraiment de la
chance à chamoni d'avoir un itinéraire
de haute montagne accessible depuis un
[Musique]
téléphérique
et c'est parti pour 20 km de descente en
majeure partie sur un glacier la plus
belle des Alpes au-delà de l'itinéraire
classique dont la difficulté n'excède
pas le niveau d'une piste rouge le
secteur offre une multitude de
hororspiste pour les plus chevronné sur
ce terrain non balisé et non sécurisé
les skieurs doivent redoubler de
vigilance et des équipements spécifiques
de sécurité procuré par votre guide sont
indispensables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là je vais vous demander de rester
exactement dans mat trace et de bien me
suivre on arrive dans ce qu'on appelle
le passage des crac c'est pas plus
difficile mais ça nécessite de vraiment
bien rester dans ma trace d'accord allez
venez par
là
ce verrou dans le glacier est un passage
obligatoire et C itinéraire en constante
évolution de décembre au mois de mai les
conditions peuvent changer
[Musique]
radicalement après avoir franchi le
passage le plus technique de la descente
une traversée permet de rejoindre refuge
une s'impose à 2450 m
d'altitude
allez on va se mettre là au soleil
contre le mur on va être très bien
filbert salut filbert gardien du requin
puisque nous voilà au refuge du requin
Mar Christophe Anaïs super super
condition un peu de vent mais la neige
est encore excellente
parfait on a une vue fantastique sur les
les S du géant on voit qu'il n'est pas
possible de les franchir par le milieu
c'est bien trop
tourmenté nous dans zone où où on peut
dire que le guide joue pleinement son
rôle à la fois au niveau de la recherche
de l'itinéraire au niveau de la
sécurisation et
CER le métier de guide pour moi est
partager une une passion avec au départ
bien entendu des clients clients qui
souvent deviennent ensuite des
amis la Compagnie des Guides de chamony
a été créée en 1821 et on peut dire que
c'est la plus ancienne compagnie en
France voire la plus ancienne compagnie
de guide au monde qui a été donc un
premier regroupement des guides
travaillant sur la sur la vallée de de
chamoni au départ uniquement originaire
de chamoni qui s'est maintenant ouverte
au à l'ensemble des guides on peut dire
puisque font partie enfin en font partie
maintenant des guides qui viennent d'un
peu
partout Olivier n'est pas natif de la
vallée mais il a été intégré dans la
tradition chamogniarde de la Compagnie
des Guides d'autres l'ont précédé des
grands noms de la montagne de Roger
Frison Roche à rebufa Lionel terré
Christophe Profi et même une femme du
pays sylvien taverern un dernier coup
d'œil au soleil sur la Dent du Géant le
montmaiin face nord des grands charmos
l'aiguille de la République et les
cornes de
Chamoin et ben nous voilà presque au
terme de notre vallée blanche il va nous
rester à descendre le petit chemin des
des motè un petit chemin forestier
sympathique prenez garde à rester sur le
chemin on descend gentiment et comme on
en a parlé tout à l'heure n'hésitez pas
à rejoindre mon camarade Stéphane pour
un petit coup de raquette en forêt hein
c'est également une ambiance très
[Musique]
sympathique ce matin en bas de la vallée
ambiance Grand Nord garantie dans les
forêts des sources de l'avyon avec
Stéphane la raquette une activité pour
les plus contemplatifs et les moins
téméraires il y a quelques années les
accompagnateurs ont remis au goût du
jour le la promenade en raquette en
ressortant des greniers les les vieilles
raquettes des grands parents la raquette
est vraiment le l'activité accessible à
tout le monde d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui avec l'évolution du
matériel on peut aller se promener avec
des raquettes très très faciles à mettre
au pied très légères on les sent plus
donc tout est bénéphique on peut se
promener vraiment sans
[Musique]
problème là il y a une trace de serre si
vous regardez bien on la reconnaît
facilement parce que d'abord c'est un
animal qui est lourd donc il s'enfonce
beaucoup dans la
neige guider ses promeneurs dans des
espaces sauvage c'est le métier de
Stéphane Berger il a lâché ses études
d'architecte et sa planche à dessin pour
une vie en pleine nature il est
accompagnateur en moyenne montagne cette
activité offre un encadrement à des
personnes attirées non pas par le ski
mais par la féerie de
l'ivver alors que Stéphane et son groupe
terminent en beauté leur sortie en
raquette sur le domaine des Planards
proche du centre-villeille les enfants
suivent leurs moniteur de ski de téléski
et un té siège offre à tous le moyen de
goûter pour la première fois aux joie de
la glisse au Planard grâce à
l'exposition au nord et à des canons à
neige l'ennegement est toujours
suffisant même tard dans la
[Musique]
saison en cette fin de journée les
nuages recouvrent peu à peu les sommets
le vent d'ouest commence à souffler pour
tous c'est de toute façon le moment de
rejoindre la vallée
afin de prévoir le programme du
lendemain une visite s'impose au centre
de chamonie à la Maison de la Montagne
unique en France l'OHM l'office de haute
monontagne informe les visiteurs sur les
conditions en altitude l'Office dispose
d'un météoite an est là pour tout vous
expliquer d'accord voilà ok mossade en
fait on a une perturbation qui arrive là
voit sur l'image satellite mon rôle bah
c'est bien d'informer les gens sur les
activités de montagne et plus
particulièrement les dangers lié aux
activités l'hiver la première chose euh
qui intéresse les gens c'est la météo
qui va faire avant de s'occuper de
est-ce qu'il y a des risque les gens ils
disent oui mais alors quel temps il va
faire demain et ben c'est là qu'on prend
ses ordinateurs qu'on les met sur images
satellite et puis ces images satellite
et nous permettent de comprendre un peu
les situations moi je reçois le bulletin
puis après j'interprète un petit peu en
fonction de en fonction de de de ce qui
se passe sur l'écran et là on voit bien
l'anticyclone des assorts qui bah qui
nous a protégé puis l'anticyclone de
Sibérie qui est plus loin quoi au niveau
de la de la prévision au niveau de la
neige Météo France établit un bulletin
neige et avalanche chaque jour et c'est
ce qui permet aux gens qui vont piste de
bah de se faire une petite idée quoi
mais bon le bulletin lui-même ne suffit
pas il faut une sacrée expérience
derrière quoi c'est pour ça que c'est
toujours mieux de sortir avec un guide
quand quand on connaît pas grandchose à
la neige de plus en plus dans les dans
les bulletins neig et avalanche les
prévisionnistes avertissent non pas que
les randonneurs skilleur mais aussi les
randonneurs à rinquiéteurs et il y a de
plus en plus de prévention qui est fait
autour de cette population qui bah qui
avance balader plutôt en forêt sur des
petits plateaux et qui maintenant
commence un petit peu à monter à droite
à gauche et qui est tout autant exposé
au risque d'avalanche que les
Randon é juste dessous de la bas d'après
Météo France d'après les météorologue
ils annoncent un temps perturbé pour
pour les jours à venir enfin même cette
nuit à partir de cette nuit ou demain
matin on a un courant perturber qui va
venir sur nous et puis après la neige
petit à petit va redescendre dans la
vallée
effectivement les prévisions
météorologiques se révèlent exactes et
les premiers flocon font leur
apparition avant de penser au ski
priorité aux axes de circulation
principalement dans le haut de la vallée
c'est à Argentière et autour que les
chutes de neige sont les plus fortes
cette fois-ci les précipitations
s'installent
durablement gu fait partie de ces
déneigeurs qui durant 4 mois d'hiver
jouent un rôle C afin de dégager le
réseau routier
ok ben on attaque la route du Tour comme
ça on fera deux passes là lé va être
content c'est une passion avant tout mon
père faisait déjà ça mon gamin est
làdedans aussi moi j'ai attaqué je te
dis en ver 77 78 pendant les gros s
avalangeche j'ai été vite
Ré et j'ai tout le temps fait ça ben je
commence souvent vers les 3h et je file
en hautour première passe VO ce que ça
donne ça fait 30 machines qui doivent
tourner au moout à l'aise en parlant du
petit Bull du petit Bob 4 jusqu' au au
Bull de 20 20 30 tonnes comment on va
les croiser là en haut
ça fait déjà un moment queon est toutes
les nuits dehors ça fait bientôt une
semaine là la plus grosse elle est
aujourd'hui hier ça pas
arrêté ça a bien fait 50 6 je pense
quand même là ça devient CR ce C les
gens ils oublient un peu ce que c'était
la neige des
moment ça ça peut durer pendant tout le
moi la fraise à neige prend le relais
travail délicat dans les rues étroites
des hameau des frasseran et de montoc
pour faire face à cette chute de neige
exceptionnelle plusieurs équipes vont
ainsi se succéder toute la nuit car le
haut de la vallée peut-être rapidement
paralysé tout doit être dégagé pour
permettre le lendemain à la vallée de
chamoni de reprendre sa vie quotidienne
et ses activités
[Musique]
touristiques 2 jours plus tard magie du
microclimat chamoniard le grand beau
temps est de retour le domaine des
grands montés est chargé de neige
sécuriser ces espaces c'est le métier de
Bernard Foucher et de son équipe de
pisteur ce matin ils sont sur le pied de
guerre aujourd'hui il y a pas eu de vent
durant la nuit ce matin Pascal va
distribuer le travail à faire sur les
pistes notamment au point de vue parce
que la hauteur de neige était environ
certains endroits 1 Miss ça trop
aujourd'hui on laiss à TR donc risque TR
pour pour
aujourd'hui enfant du pays Pascal C le
professionnalisme et l'esprit despisteur
des grands montés il en connaî les
moindres recoins Combes et crevasses en
10 minutes tous se retrouve à 3200 m
d'altitude on est une dizaine à monter
au grand mon et on se réparti sur les
différentes pistes au départ des grands
il y a qu pistes au départ des
grandsbaliser se en groupe de parbin on
est parbinome on fait le balisage de
toutes les
[Musique]
pistes bon tu vois comme ce matin on a
fait les escaliers un petit coup des
escaliers après on passe à la rimée la
rimée ouverte un coup en la
bouche c'est la beauté du site c'est la
haute montagne c'est un secteur
glaciaire c'est tout ce qui fait que le
travail ici est pour moi différent
quand j'en changer pour rien au monde
moi je me PL à dire de faire sa passion
son métier c'est fabule quoi c'est un
peu magique c'est un peu un rêve de
travailler ici qu
sur ce domaine qui dessert un espace
hors piste unique au monde les pisteurs
sont bien plus que de simples
auxiliaires du peleton de gendarmerie de
haute montagne leur champ d'intervention
Balit tous les secteurs à proximité des
pistes qui peuvent être atteints depuis
le sommet des différentes remontées
mécaniques aujourd'hui les pisteurs
effectuent un exercice de sauvetage en
crevasse on arrive à de sur une crevasse
on a de sac il y a un des secouristes
qui va s'occuper de rentrer en contact
avec le gars qui est dans la crevasse
dans un premier temps il va sonder toute
la zone une fois qu'il a sondé la zone
il pourra travailler à pied sans risquer
de tomber dans un autre trou dans le
coin il va planter assez rapidement un
pieux se servir d'un bout de corde pour
aller à proximité de la la crevasse
c'est bon il
répond alors là on installe le
treuil
c'est donc l'appareil qui va servir à
sortir la victime de la crevasse et
remonter également le
secouriste passutour des
épaes
j'arrive ça va
monsieur ça va être
bon
aider que qui attendre
[Musique]
l'élico au grand monté les pisteurs
doivent être toujours prêts à faire face
aux interventions les plus délicates car
dès l'ouverture du domaine des dizaines
de skieurs de tout poil se lancent à
l'assaut de la neige poudreuse parfois
sans connaître les dangers du terrain
comme pour la Vallée Blanche pour jouir
pleinement des itinéraires hors piste
être accompagné d'un guide moniteur est
ici vivement
[Musique]
conseillé 10h du matin première
alerteu je
t'écoute on un petit souci rejo
les pisteurs de la vallée sont habitués
à travailler en étroite collaboration
avec Pascal brun et son hélicoptère le
secteur des grands montés et du glacier
d'Argentière est l'un des plus
fréquentés par les skieur de toute
nationalité et les jours de beau temps
les interventions de secours sont
proportionnelles à cette
[Musique]
affluence
un pisteur secouriste est toujours à
bord de la machine et en moins de 10
minutes le blessé est rapatrié dans la
vallée jusqu'à la base de Pascal brun
installé au pied des grands mon le
blessé est immédiatement pris en charge
par les services d'urgence de chamoni
mais pour Pascal les jours de be temps
la ronde infernale se
poursuit euh Julie est parti voir il y a
blessé au col ça serait un genou donc on
va voir si la personne remonte pas les
escaliers
[Applaudissements]
ou la plus belle utilisation de
l'hélicoptère reste celle du secours à
ce titre nous avons le privilège et la
chance de participer de temps en temps à
la demande du secours montagne à chamoni
à des interventions qui sont rarement
euh rarement
facile natif de chamoni j'ai la chance
d'évoluer depuis de nombreuses années
dans ce massif du Mont-Blanc aujourd'hui
ma j'allais dire malgré les 12000 he de
vol et quelques à mon actif je prends
toujours autant de plaisir à évoluer
dans ce massif c'est évident que le le
métier que je fais est un métier
passion Pascal connaît les moindres
recoins du massif du monde mon blanc et
s déjouer les pièges de l'aérologie en
hiver il a un contrat avec la commune de
chamoni afin d'assurer les secours sur
les pistes travaux d'aménagement en
altitude tournage de films variés
ravitaillement des refuges ou vol
touristiqu sont les autres volets de son
[Musique]
activité
grâce à Pascal retour au grand monté à
proximité du village d'Argentière à 7 km
en amont de chamoni au cœur du massif du
Montblanc sous l'aiguille Verte et les
dru la renommée internationale de ce
domaine est dû à l'étendue et à la
variété de ces itinéraires répartis sur
trois versants le glacier d'Argentière
l'oignon et la
pendant depuis de nombreuses années des
skieurs passionnés de glisses et de
hautes montagnes de toutes les
nationalités se donnent rendez-vous au
grand monté Roland Créton natif de la
vallée et guide de haute montagne trace
ici les plus belles courbes
elle est belle tu vois on vient de la
descendre à ski hein même là elle est un
peu dure mais c'est quand même un très
bel endroit et puis là c'est une belle
neige soufflée et tout qui est pas
dangereuse puis comme tout le tout le
coin des grands monta est magnifique
hein tu connais aussi bien que moi le
glacier tu vois derrière c'est il y a
partout des possibilités
incroyables moi qui a qui quand même
travaillé une dizaine d'années au piste
déjà je peux en parler en tant que
pisteur à ce niveaul c'est l'un des plus
beaux domaines qui existe au niveau de
la qualité du ski d'une part par le
déniveler le cadre la pente tout ce
qu'on veut et puis la qualité de la
neige là on est fin février la neige est
toujours aussi bonne
quoi on fait encore un joli coup de ski
et on va à mon atelier Argentière et on
se retrouve
là-bas
[Applaudissements]
suivons Roland qui termine avec une
technique impeccable ses 2000 m de
descente jusqu'à la vallée aujourd'hui
son activité principale c'est
[Musique]
l'artisanat le lieu de travail il est
pas difficile à décrire hein regarde ce
qu'il y a autour hein je veux dire c'est
un des plus beaux endroits qu'il est
alors surtout là Argentière derrière
l'église là c'est le c'est pour moi le
plus bel endroit d'arggentière et
maintenant ben ça fait partie de ma vie
pour les 3/4 de l'année quoi puisque
j'en j'en travaille et j'en vis quoi
puisque le guide ça reste un tout petit
bout de l'année quoi la vasque est en
Arol c'estàdire en pin sambros et le
bois a quand même une petite histoire
c'est des bois que j'avais trouvé en al
baladé et puis c'est des arbres qui
étaient sec sur pied donc qui étaient
mort et à ce moment-là tu peux les
acheter parce que si tu veux la rle
quand il est sain et vert c'est des bois
protégés donc tu peux pas les
avoir tous les objets qui sont devant
vous sont les objets qui sont taillé
dans les
branches là par exemple cet oiseau là
c'est de
LIF celui-ci c'est du noyer la statuette
qui est là c'est du poirier il y a du
pommier du prunier également les oiseaux
sont en prunier là la statue derrière
est en
pommier
début de ma sculpture il est là ça c'est
l'une des premières que j'ai faite c'est
un fusil que j'avais refait que j'avais
acheté un vieux fusil à chien qui
fonctionne très bien puisque j'ai chassé
avec j'avais racheté un morceau de noyer
j'avais la crosse ça c'est le départ
c'est vraiment le départ de ma sculpture
quoi ça c une Ronse de noyer avec SC un
grand Téra un écritoir ça j'en avais
fait quelquesuns
également
c'est l'époque de la
chasse ça c
été bonne vingtaine d'années de de vie
de chasseur pu après j'ai ça c'est un
truc j'ai complètement arrêté maintenant
ça c'est quelques trophées de
Ch on a de la chance que les matinées et
les nuits soi fraîches surtout on peut
aller faire l'école de glace en face en
dessus de la crémerie là juste face à
nous là on voit depuis ici les cascades
là il y a des écoles de glace qui se
font il y a plein de choses c'est
magnifique
[Musique]
l'alpinisme hivernal n'est pas réservé
qu'à une élite à 20 minutes d'Argentière
un terrain idéal et facilement
accessible permet au guide marsuil
d'initier ses clients à l'escalade sur
des cascades de
[Musique]
glace donc là tu vois on va grimper
juste à gauche là des qure personnes on
va faire une petite moulinette c'estàd
la corde en haut moi en bas comme ça je
vais bien pouvoir vous conseiller pour
les positions des piolettes et des
crampons et puis une fois que ça ira
bien vous aurez bien ça ben on va faire
plusieurs longueurs pour monter jusquau
Sam m du Mont Blanc l'intérêt c'est de
bien acquérir la technique pour pouvoir
aller plus loin et plus haut en montagne
c'est c'est de s'entraîner en fait comme
on fait de la falaise ou du mur
d'escalade pour le rocher on fait de la
cascade de glace sur glacier ou sur
torangelé pour pour tout ce qui est
technique
glaciaire donc pour la cascade de glace
le matériel minimum c'est une bonne
paire de chaussures déjà c'està-dire
chaussure de haute montagne se met
l'armé une bonne paire de crampon il des
pointes avant plutôt affuté puisque la
glace va être assez dure casque
indispensable à cause des projections
quand on plante les piolets un piolet
pour chaque main un piolet technique
donc les lames inversé par rapport à la
la pioche habituelle et puis un baudrier
pour s'attacher avec la corde puis après
le leader a besoin de broche à glace
pour pouvoir mettre les assurances
d'anneau de sangle de
moussequeton en poussant sur tes pieds
et pas tirant avec tes
bras on est on est au premier lait ils
vont vraiment bien la glace est
excellente aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire elle
est pas trop froide pas trop du pas trop
cassante ils se débrouill très bien ils
ont pas d'appréhension particulière donc
on va continuer en plusieurs longueurs
jusqu'au sommet de la cascade on va on
va progresser avec un un mur un petit
peu plus long et un petit peu plus raide
plus
loin
super toute personne en forme qui a
envie de de découvrir une nouvelle
activité sportive he quand même peut
venir la faire c'est pas du du tout une
question de de sensation forte de trompe
la mort et de choses comme ça faut la
faire on s'adapte après aux gens il y a
des gens qui vont progresser très vite
parce que ils sont dans leur élément
comme on dit en comment quelques
quelques sorties vont vite être dans du
raid par contre là il faut quand même je
dirais quand même plusieurs saisons de
de pratique de glace plusieurs années de
pratique de glace avant
d'être on va dire un
fa un peu un peu éprouvant surtout pour
la deè la deuxè gette qu'on a fait mais
ça c'est vraiment une découverte et je
suis pas
déçu sur ces murs gelés si la joie
d'acquérir une bonne technique et
d'admirer l'isance de leur guide rayonne
sur le visage de ses candidats aux
émotions fortes en revanche en bas dans
la vallée pour les plus jeunes une
course de ski de fond est
[Musique]
organisée clin d'œil à la Grande Course
hivernale la vasalopette la minivasa
organisée par Roland Ravanel met en
action les scolaires des pays du
Mont-Blanc
5 4 3 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous ces enfants de Chamon sont motivés
par la course et soutenu par le regard
attentif de leurs instituteurs et bien
entendu de leurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parents
en forêt le long des morenes près des
torrents les parcours de ski de fond de
la vallée ont forgé bien des
vocations malgré sa réputation chamoni
se doit d'avoir une stratégie
événementiel tousim rajunir son image
est une nécessité ce soir une
compétition de
se déroule sous les feux des projecteurs
au plan
[Musique]
entre modernité et tradition la capitale
de la glisse sous toutes ses formes
possède une solide culture nordique le
guide moniteur de ski Roger Ravanel et
le maître d'œuvre des rondes
nocturnes dans la vallée de chamoni il y
a toujours des ski de fond il y a un
circuit à chamoni qui est très beau un
circuit argentiè et un circuit à
valorine depuis une quinzaine d'années
donc on avait pas fait de ronde nocturne
en ville ici même à chamoni et quand on
voit l'engouement qu'il y a c'est
extraordinaire faut savoir que les ronde
nocturne la première a été créée en 1967
je pas mettre en avant mais c'est moi
qui l' fait Argentière il y avait les
équipes de France c'était juste avant
les Jeux de 68 et nocturne c'est un peu
le poumon de du SK on voit tous les
parents on voit tout le
[Musique]
monde nousurons ce soirie alandreous
Emmanuel t les de tous les deux l'école
militaire de haute montagne de
[Musique]
Chamon cet hiver grâce au bon enigement
au cilleette compétition originale
participe à l'animation de la stationord
de aménager dans les rues où des tonnes
de neiges sont amassé l'ambiance
vinchaud hraclette est
[Applaudissements]
garantie 4e position pour Chamon 5e
position le V
et en relais sous les encouragements
d'une foule galvanisée les skilleurs de
fond enchaînne les boucles de 5 à 8 km
au cours de 5 courses
successives on a eu la chance ce soir
d'avoir chamonie Emmanuel jier Alexandre
Rousel et merci à eux je dirais qu'il
nous ont vraiment fait un énorme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
spectacle depuis les premiers Jeux
Olympiques en 192
chamoni possède l'image des sports
d'hiver traditionnels mais aujourd'hui
pour une tribu de skieurs venu de tous
horizons la marque de fabrique de la
vallée en hiver c'est le free ride une
forme de ski hors limite pratiqué en
toute liberté par des fous de la glisse
à la recherche de sensation forte dans
les pentes les plus
[Musique]
audacieuses extrme du ski piste le
freeide compte de nombreux adeptes
professionnels grâce à des années
d'expérience le guide moniteur Stéphan
dan en est un de ses plus fervants
ambassadeurs il n'hésite pas à monter à
pied pour trouver et tracer la pente de
ses
[Musique]
rêves le fre ride le SK libre en fait
qui nécessite la connaissance du de la
neige du de soi-même aujourd'hui il y a
des marques qui nous aident qui
utilisent notre image pour pour
communiquer sur les produits pour faire
évoluer le matériel comme les skis par
[Musique]
exemple équipé de de ski plus large au
talon et en spatule Stéphane
inconditionnel de ce ski acrobatique
c'est détecter les saus et les corniches
il maîtrise parfaitement sa descente cet
hiver il participe à l'organisation de
l'épreuve Chamon ette nelle
[Musique]
discipline des montagnes de l'Alaska à
celle des Alpes le freide a ses
compétitions et la vallée de chamoni
grâce à sa réputation est un des haut
lieux
incontournables depuis 5 ans cet
événement se dispute sur leaine du
brvant
aujourd'hui éip a l'hélicoptère de PASC
BR assure la
[Musique]
sécurité les 50 plus fines spatules de
la planète Gliss viennent faire hurler
la neige sur des pentes à 45 de d'in
maison parsemé de barres rocheuse et sur
une dénivélation de 600 m pas de chrono
pas de porte aucun itinéraire imposé
sauf la ligne
[Musique]
d'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les compétiteurs sont départagés par un
jury qui attribue des points selon le
choix de ligne de pente la technique et
la prise de risque cette année les
vainqueurs se partageront une somme de
15000 €. Stéphan Dan est satisfait du
bon déroulement de cette 5e édition pour
lui la sécurité prime avant tout et les
prouesses des participants ne doivent
pas faire oublier qu'ils sont avant tout
des sportifs de haut
[Musique]
niveau on a eu un peu au début une image
de ces compètes un peu trop peut-être
trop extrême avec des gros sauts un peu
casscou des cascadeurs maintenant ce que
veulent voir les vuf c'est vraiment du
beau ski maîtrisé contrôlé et très
fluide et très rapide
même si les jeunes même si tout le monde
veut essayer de faire ça ça vient pas
par hasard il faut il faut faut
apprendre il faut une vraiment passer
beaucoup de temps sur les skis et bien
se connaître avant de avant de se lâcher
dans les pentes et de faire n'importe
[Musique]
quoi le guide moniteur connaît
parfaitement le terrain horors piste
chamoniard et chaque jour de bonnes
conditions météo doit être consacré à
l'entraînement
[Musique]
alors que Stéphane achève sa descente
nous retrouvons Lorine sur un terrain
plus adapté à ses
enfants après toutes ces rencontres et
ces activités partager vous vous rendez
compte qu'à chamoni l'hiver tout est
possible grâce à son passé et à son for
formidable domaine chamoni mérite
vraiment son nom de capitale du ski
allez les enfants on continue on y va
chamoni est une station au multiples
visages aujourd'hui elle doit gérer son
succès pour préserver son âme et son
environnement cette vallée est une
merveille que chaque année près de 5
millions de visiteurs viennent découvrir
sa ressource naturelle et son trésor
dans une vie de skieur le domaine du
massif du Mont-Blanc est une étape
incontournable
[Musique]